This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich. We are in Saint Paul,
Minnesota. Coming to you live
from the Fitzgerald Theater.
Our subject today is the
war of the worlds broadcast.
Originally on October 30th, 1938
okay, now I'm gonna ask the
house for a show of hands.
The question for the house is,
do you think that somebody else could
imagine the broadcast using the exact same
script more or less? Also
with Martians also invading,
also interrupting the musical things.
Same deal after all the publicity
from the 1938 broadcast.
Could you do it twice?
Show of hands, please. Oh,
some of you don't think
so. Look, if we could, if,
if there wasn't another one of these,
what would we be doing for the next one?
Well, so those of you
who've raised your hands,
let's say it's about 75% of you,
you are correct because it has happened
again and I want to tell you a story.
It an amazing story,
really an underreported story of a war
of the worlds reenactment happened in the
mountains of Quito, Ecuador,
1949 we were very lucky.
We had a reporter, Tony Fields who
happened to be traveling there.
We asked him to do a couple of interviews
for people who heard it or were there
and he brought back some tape and
played it for me in studio. Alright,
so Tony set the scene for
me. 1949 Kito. Where's Quito?
Quito is the capital of Ecuador.
Quito is in the middle of the
mountains in the Andes mountains.
[inaudible] and small town, big
town. Quito. Now is a big city.
At the time it was a pretty small city.
It had a quarter of a million people,
you know, 300,000 tops. Um,
the word that everybody who I spoke to
use to describe the way the Kito was in
1949 was trying, Hilo
[inaudible] said, I want to see that.
And we drank like tranquil. Exactly.
It is what it sounds like.
Tranquil, calm, chill and radio.
Quito was the most popular radio station.
Everybody listened to it. So
those are your basic ingredients.
You've got a small town
population, 250,000.
You have one major radio station,
which also happened to be in the same
building as the one major newspaper,
El Comercio and the leader of the
radio station. The guy who ran it,
he a devious fellow by the
name of Leonardo pious.
One day someone shows up with a
script for Orson wells, not HD wills.
Orson Welles version of war of the world
gives it to Leonardo Paez. He reads,
it says, brilliant, we've
got to do this here in Quito.
They insert local place names, you know,
so instead of the Martians
landing in New Jersey,
they would land and click the core Yao,
which is on the outskirts of Quito.
They write in parts for government
officials. The minister of the interior,
the mayor of Quito is their
actors or real government.
These would be actors doing impressions
and doing impressions. That's right.
Not only that, pious got
his bosses at the newspaper,
El Comercio to agree to run little
articles in the newspaper in the two days
leading up to the broadcast reporting.
That strange objects had been
seen in a sky's over Keith though.
Wow. So he set out to screw
with people basically. I mean,
he was planting paranoia.
It really seems like he wanted people
to believe what they were hearing that
night.
[inaudible]
okay, so Saturday, February 12th,
1949 the day of the broadcast,
all day long listeners
here and announcement.
When does notice and [inaudible] that
there's going to be a special performance
by duo Benitez balance? Yeah.
They need this balance here.
[inaudible] at that time,
we're one of the most popular
musical acts in town in Rodeo. Quito.
Why don't you cue up a
track number four? Hmm.
[inaudible]
eight o'clock rolls around Beneatha's
Valencia launches into their performance.
They play a few songs
[inaudible]
and suddenly there's an interruption.
some sort of strange kind of
interference like sound. Okay.
Hell, what do you mean? Like
static signal, the static, the signals,
you know, something's wrong with it.
It's not coming in quite right.
Wait, what was that? Well,
it turns out that Leonardo,
the pies in addition to the other
tricks they had up his sleeve,
he had a sound effects guy in the
corner that was creating this sounds
like when it garrison
Keillor's guys kind of thing.
That's right. Can keep everyone
[inaudible].
Eventually the music stops and
Leonardo Paez comes on the air and says
[inaudible] dear listeners,
excuse the technical difficulties.
There seems to be some sort of atmospheric
conditions interfering with the radio
Quito signal. But you are the thing to
radio. Keep those brought to you by,
you know, such and such. And
now back to this balance. Yeah.
[inaudible]
so we hear another couple songs and then
there's another interruption up in soon
it's laying out the payers again. And
this time, this time it's a news flash.
What do I do? So now we're on
script. That's right. That's right.
They send Paez out to
report from the scene.
We'll go Kojo and pies is doing the
play by play. You know, what is this?
Oh my God, the cops in school,
you know, from the clinicals.
And here come the heat rate.
Hi, is this fry?
You can wait, wait, wait, wait.
Do we have forget reenactments?
Do we have a copy of the, the
real broadcast from that night?
All we have are descriptions.
There is no existing recording
of what was broadcast that night.
And, and you'll understand
why in a second.
[inaudible]
so while I was down there in Quito,
I interviewed a bunch of people about
what happened that night by all accounts
at work.
Oh,
outside, it was sheer Mei.
Everything that happened next
happened extremely quickly.
People poured out into the
streets, people were running,
but they didn't know where to run.
The spaceship supposedly was
in the north of the city,
but there's black cloud of gas was
in the south. And a lot of them,
they actually did what any
good Catholic would do.
They made a beeline for the church
[inaudible]
the church because, because they were,
they thought they'd be
safe there or perhaps,
or perhaps they just wanted to get right
with God before the world ended their
even reports. And I wasn't
able to confirm this,
but there were reports of men confessing
to adultery right there in front of
their wives and priests.
Absolving whole crowds at once.
Queue up at track track 10
[inaudible] in
[inaudible] [inaudible] who
is a long time journalist,
worked for many years at the newspaper.
He was listening with his family.
They all believed it.
They all ran outside,
found a taxi cab to the kids and rest
them ran behind the taxi cab. Eh,
they were gonna [inaudible] the city
[inaudible] and he tells me that
he sees going the other way.
This convoy military trucks
filled with soldiers. Do we
real trucks, real military bans,
real military vans of the real soldiers
and cops behind them and they're
screaming towards the north of
the city. Where are they going?
They're going to cut the coal
yow to fight the Martians. Yeah.
So if you, if you had any doubt at this
point that this was a, well maybe it's,
maybe it's real, maybe it's not. And
once you saw this military events,
you were like, oh, bleep, I've
got to get the hell out. Right.
Wa does. Does everybody in
Quito believe like the army?
Peep, didn't someone call
the general beforehand?
Say Tonight we're having a broad day.
The mayor or someone who sounded an awful
like the mayor was on the radio saying
Martians were invading. And
so if you're the army guy,
you're going to go check it
out or you have to protect.
But the mayor didn't call
the general before a no, no.
So then what happens
at the end of the show?
It assuming it ends the way they
always do [inaudible] then what?
Well, they a storm, the radio station,
let's go ahead. By the time of
broadcast ended and it was announced,
but the whole thing was a play.
A huge crowds were in the streets and
word that it was a hoax spread pretty
quickly. All that fear turned
pretty quickly to anger
by nine 30 there's a few
hundred outside the station.
At some point this boxer shows up.
They're just been a match in the Central
Plaza and the boxer shows up and he's
driving this truck and the
truck is full of rocks.
So what rocks is full of rocks? Yeah.
And people start hurling
the rocks at the station,
at the windows and windows or shattering.
They managed to break into the,
to the ground floor where
the printing presses,
they're smashing printing presses.
At some point some people in the crowd
materialize and they have these flaming
torches and it just goes up
like a matched it. So, so,
so where people hurt during this
six people died. Oh
really? Yeah, most escaped.
There was about 50 people in the
building. Most got up to the roof,
jump to adjoining buildings, but six
people died according to a reporter, Tony,
uh, one guy stayed behind.
The last guy on the air that night
was a man by the name of Luis Beltran.
Maria, are you there?
Yes, I'm here.
Okay. This is Maria
Beltran Testagrossa, uh,
Louis Beltran's daughter and Maria,
you are listening to everything
that just came before this. Yeah.
Tell us the story from Your Dad's
perspective. Uh, from here forward.
He was on the air. What was he doing?
Uh, well he was, he was on
the air. He was the, I guess,
hosting the music program and also doing
some of the interruption with the, uh,
with the bogus, uh,
[inaudible] at the point at which
the fire started. What was he saying?
Well, at that point when he realized
the magnitude of the situation,
he went back on the air and began pleading
for help pleading for assistance from
the police and the fire department.
But uh, as you said before,
no help came because the police
were going to fight the Martian.
Yeah.
And uh, eventually he was
the last one left and uh,
and he jumped out the window.
I'd get from the either the
third or fourth floor onto a, uh,
second floor balcony
and to break the fall,
I guess instinctively you
want to break the fall,
he grabbed onto the railing of that
balcony and he was completely engulfed in
flames at that point. And the skin on
his hands just remained on the balcony.
It was like a barbecue grill. And, uh,
from there he jumped to the
ground, but before he jumped,
he was pleading to the crowd to I
guess catch him, but they didn't.
He landed on some men, broke legs, arm,
ribs, everything. And
compounded by the very,
very serious burns that
he had all over his body.
So he landed at the feet
of an angry mob. What a,
an angry mob. And He, uh,
he recall that as he's losing
consciousness, he just heard somebody say,
just let him die in peace. Although
some of the articles that I read,
they try to throw him
back into the building.
Oh, really? If someone,
uh, grabbed him and put him in a
jeep to take him to the hospital,
just the bystander and you know,
he had so many scars here as
children, like my brother and I would,
would play with his scars.
You would trace them with our finger in
and ask them what happened. You know,
how we got the scars? And he would
tell us about the fire that, you know,
the building had burned and
he would tell us about that.
What would he tell you? The whole
story or how much of this did you know?
Dory, he would just give
us in just in broad terms,
but he had been in a building that caught
fire. Uh, he also told us, you know,
he had been a radio announcer, but, uh,
as children we didn't really ask him.
Maybe had we been older and asked them,
he would have told us the whole story.
Hmm.
And we should say that your dad stayed
behind to try and help other people get
out of the building. Well, let
me ask you a question though. Uh,
your dad obviously is a hero,
but given the fact that he was one
of the voices that created the panic,
do you feel some sort
of ambivalence about,
did he feel some sort
I don't know, in retrospect
whether he did or not.
I'm sure there must've been some
ambivalence. But from what I understand,
the story was kept,
it was very top secret so that even the
employees did not know what was going to
be broadcast during that
music program. Really.
I don't know at what point he
was informed of the details.
So I don't know really
how we felt about it.
I wish I had had an
opportunity to ask him.
Hmm. Well listen, Maria,
thank you so much for your time and
joining us here and yeah, thanks. Perfect.
[inaudible]
I just want to know what happened to the
guy who planned the hoax. Uh, well, uh,
he uh, he got out through the
roof like a lot of others.
He hopped to the next building,
hid out for a few days,
and then fled the country to
Venezuelan. Never to return,
never to return, never to return.
But I should say that among the six
people who died that night was his
girlfriend and a nephew of his. Okay.
So the 1949 Quito broadcast
caused a whole lot of trouble.
The 1938 New York broadcasts
Now everybody here before who raised
their hand and thought that this could
happen again. You are right again,
Lau, Buffalo, 1968
on a weird night, nobody came in.
Nobody with Jackson off
shore on the radio hunting,
going to get it all together between
now and about midnight a little bit
thereafter, whatever. It's
the height of the Vietnam war,
Wk BW broadcast.
It's a fascinating version of the war
of the worlds updated for the time.
It sounds kind of like your [inaudible]
basic DJ set until you hear this.
What is your toe down?
And you just handed me something here
that I'm much supposed to read. Thank you.
Thank you Joe. Uh, let's
see. The NASA national,
the national spatial and there
are not exert administration.
Those people have alerted
all their space watch and uh,
facilities to be on the alert for unusual
communication difficulties tonight,
I suppose before the,
a federal referred to the explosions on
the planet Mars and study was not known
if they would have the same effect on
earth communications as similar explosions
on the surface of the sun have,
I guess you're talking about sun
spots and things like that. So, uh,
I don't know what it's shadowed.
It means that it's going to be hard
to hear communications from national.
I don't, can you hear me? Daughters' South
Carolina. As long as you can hear kv,
whatever's you'd make about
communication, rock and roll.
[inaudible] any objection off?
Can you take what your hand Halloween
night getting it all together.
Where it will you KBW
w KBW broadcast followed the same
structure as the original broadcast.
We've heard tonight long stretches of
music than the news bulletins than the
send me realistic field
reports. Here's one of them.
What do you got? You got walking
injuries or are a real bad,
you got the same vivid
descriptions of Martian.
Hi by God we all got it, Don.
I got it. They all got it.
And according to the station manager
Jeff K, he kept the same outcome.
People bought it.
Hello? Hello.
Police and telephone company reported
to Wk VW that they received more than
4,000 phone calls.
The Canadian military
authorities dispatched military
units to the peace bridge,
the Rainbow Bridge and the
Queenstown Bridge to repel invaders.
The story was carried the next day
by 47 newspapers in the country wide.
And on the night of the show and
during the show, you're not impressed.
Bureaus up and down the east coast of
America where a besieged by phone calls
asking about the Martian
invasion in buffalo. Incredible.
You're absolutely right. It is incredible.
[inaudible]
thanks to the folks at Wk BW buffalo for
that. What is this music, by the way?
This is the disco version
of war of the worlds 1978
there's a discovered, still sells a
lot of copies. You'd be surprised.
Here's the obvious question to ask.
What does this keep working? Oh,
well that's a difficult question.
I came across a psychology
professor. I'm Richard Gehrig.
I am a professor of psychology in the
cognitive experimental program at Stony
Brook University.
He has this notion Richard Gehrig does
and it route people are suckers for
stories. We just cannot help
ourselves. When a story starts,
you just kind of go, whoa.
Think the norm is to fall into the story
and that it's unusual to sort of keep
yourself from falling it
by. Favorite example is a,
there's a scene in gold finger. God.
Yeah, the all time best James Bond
movie. I think we're bond is tied down,
spread eagle on a piece of metal and
there's this laser coming toward him,
which really looks like
it's gonna cut him into.
And even as I'm saying that right now,
I'm starting to feel a little bit of
anxiety because as a picture you get in my
head and picture that laser coming
toward him and you know, spoiler alert,
he doesn't actually get split
into by the laser yet. Sorry,
but here's the thing.
Go and watch the movie now and see if
you can get through that scene without
experience. Suspense.
And it really seems to say something very
powerful and strong about how immerse
we can become
in the narrative world.
[inaudible]
the thing is,
we do go in, Leo all fall
into these stories. He says,
it's just the way we are built
for hundreds of thousands
of years. Our memories,
our friendships, our sense
of family, our kinship.
We build our identities from stories,
stories that we tell and
stories that we hear.
Well, let's take a break coming
up. Terror in the toilets,
python in the Potty, and more scary
stories on this edition of Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
We will continue in a moment.